The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Our lecture today is called
'Rolle's Theorem and Its
Consequences'.
And I suppose we could've made
a take off on what goes up
must come down, and say that
what Rolle's theorem says
intuitively is that what goes
up smoothly and comes down
smoothly must level
off somewhere.
OK?
Now because that may sound too
easy to understand, let's
cloak that in the language of
more formal mathematics.
Rolle's theorem says this.
Let 'f' be defined and
continuous on the closed
interval from 'a' to 'b'.
In other words, what?
The domain of 'f' is the closed
interval from 'a' to 'b'.
The graph of 'f' is unbroken
on this interval.
And differentiable in the open
interval from 'a' to 'b'.
In other words, you want the
function to be continuous on
the entire interval, but for
differentiability, you only
require that it be smooth,
differentiable, in the
interior of the interval,
in the open interval.
Suppose also that 'f of
a' and 'f of b' are 0.
Then, what Rolle's theorem says
is that 'f prime of c',
the derivative of 'f of x', must
be 0 for some number 'c',
at least one number
'c', in the open
interval from 'a' to 'b'.
Now what this thing says
intuitively is simply this,
suppose you have a curve that is
unbroken for all values of
'x' between 'a' and
'b' inclusively.
Suppose the curve is smooth.
Suppose the curve starts here
and ends here, then what we're
saying is there must be some
point in here where the curve
levels off.
In other words, someplace where
you have a horizontal
tangent, which is what 'f prime
of c' equals 0 means.
In this particular diagram, this
would be the value of 'c'
that we're talking about.
By the way, I think the proof
is intuitively clear.
Namely, if the curve never
leaves the x-axis, then it's
leveled off for the
entire domain.
And if the curve does leave the
x-axis, for example, if
the curve starts to rise, OK,
since it must eventually get
back to the x-axis when 'b' is
0, it must ultimately begin to
fall again.
Well, if the curve goes from
rising to falling,
it must have what?
Since it's coming up and then
going down, it must attain a
maximum value.
Because the curve is unbroken
and smooth, as we saw in our
previous lecture, the maximum
value is characterized by the
derivative at that
point being 0.
In fact, the analytic proof is
precisely what we've just
said, only translated into more
mathematical language.
By the way, I would like to
make a slight aside here,
because I think it sometimes
gets confusing to students to
see, why do you say that the
function has to be continuous
on the closed interval, but
differentiable only in the
open interval?
I thought you might like to see
a contrived example as to
what goes wrong if you allow the
curve to be broken at the
end points.
See, all I'm thinking of
is something like this.
Suppose I say, look, let's
define a curve as follows.
At 'x' equals 'a' and
'x' equals 'b', the
curve will be 0.
So in other words, it'll
cross the x-axis.
Then immediately, for 'x'
greater than 'a', the curve
jumps up to here, comes down
along this line, and then, you
see, when 'x' equals 'b', it
jumps down here again.
In other words, why
not let the curve
be defined as follows?
It will be 0 at these
two endpoints.
It'll be this curve on
the open interval.
Notice in this contrived example
that 'f of a' and 'f
of b' are both equal to 0, but
there is no place in the open
interval where the curve has
a horizontal tangent line.
In other words, the significance
is you've got to
be sure that the curve doesn't
get broken at the ends,
because with these gaps,
all sorts of
crazy things can happen.
Now, just as in our previous
lecture, there are some rather
important cautions that have to
be taken in understanding
Rolle's theorem.
As simple as it is, we have to
be sure that we understand
exactly what's really
happening here.
The first caution is that
Rolle's theorem is what we
mathematicians call an
'existence theorem'.
It says, under certain
conditions, there exists at
least one number 'c' that
has a certain property.
It doesn't tell us how
many "c's" there are.
It doesn't tell us where
to find them.
It just says, what?
There exists at least
one such 'c'.
And the point is, you must
be careful to remember--
so let's take an example.
Here's 'a', here's 'b'.
If the function is continuous
and smooth, in other words, if
the graph is continuous and
smooth, all we're saying is
that at least one number between
'a' and 'b', the
curve, must possess a
horizontal tangent.
There may be more than one.
You see, the curve, for
example, could do
something like this.
See, in other words, here is one
value of 'c', which we'll
call 'c1', horizontal
tangent here.
Here's another value, which
we'll call 'c2', horizontal
tangent here.
See, again, the meaning
of at least one.
Secondly, we must make sure
that we remember that the
curve is smooth.
Meaning what?
That the function is
differentiable.
Now I'm taking the liberty
of drawing
these things in freehand.
There's some mixed emotions
here, if I draw the diagrams
too smoothly all the time, you
lose the significance of
what's going on because
of the picture.
And if I draw them freehand
all the time, you won't
understand what I'm
doing, because I
don't draw very well.
But I think here we can
get away with this.
What I'm driving at is this.
Let's suppose you have
'a' and 'b' here.
Let's suppose that the function,
the curve that we're
drawing, passes through
these two points.
But suppose there happens to
be a sharp corner in here.
Maybe the curve goes like this,
it goes up like this,
then very abruptly comes
down like this.
Notice, what?
That the curve is continuous.
It does reach a local maximum.
But the point is, for this
particular value of 'c', 'f
prime of c' is not
0 by default.
Namely, 'f prime of c'
doesn't even exist.
So in other words, Rolle's
theorem doesn't apply if you
don't have differentiabilities.
I want to make sure you see
where each of the parts of the
hypotheses for the
theorem are used.
By the way, here's another
interesting result, which has
nothing to do with the statement
of the theorem, but
again, another piece of evidence
as to why we like to
shy away from functions which
are not single value.
See, for example, suppose you
allowed the function to be
multivalued, and you say, OK,
I want the curve to pass
through here and here.
And I want it to be smooth.
But the curve does not have
to be single value.
Notice what you can do.
You could have a curve that
does something like this.
I don't know.
Now you see, there will be
a point 'c' where the
derivative will be 0.
Even as badly as I've drawn
this, I think roughly
speaking, we can see that 'c'
would be something like this.
Notice, however, that in
Rolle's theorem, the
statement is what?
That 'c' must be on the open
interval from 'a' to 'b'.
If the function is not single
value, as long as the curve is
smooth, there will be places
where the curve levels off.
But the x-coordinate of the
point at which the curve
levels off may not be
in the interval--
may not be, it could be, but
it might not be, I should
say-- in the open interval
from 'a' to 'b'.
This is a very, very
important result.
In fact, I'll have reason to
make reference to this in a
little while later
in the lecture.
I couldn't make reference to
it later earlier in the
lecture, I guess.
The fourth assumption here is
also an aside, and it's one
that's rather crucial.
In most textbooks in which
Rolle's theorem is stated, the
condition is what?
That 'f of a' equals
'f of b' equals 0.
It turns out that this is too
restrictive, that essentially,
all you need is 'f of
a' equals 'f of b'.
What I mean by that is, let's
suppose 'f of a' is not 0.
Let's suppose this height
represents 'f of a'.
What I'm saying is suppose
that 'f of a' and
'f of b' are equal.
What that means is, if I want to
think of a new axis, which
I call the 'x sub 1' axis--
see, with respect to the 'x sub
1' axis, the curve crosses
the axis at these two points.
In other words, notice that as
long as these two points are
at the same level, the same
argument that we used to prove
Rolle's theorem goes through
unimpeded over here.
Namely, we say what?
What goes up smoothly and
comes down smoothly--
because it has to come down,
because it comes back to the
same level here-- must reach a
point someplace in here where
it levels off.
So these are the four cautions
that I'd like you to look at
when we view Rolle's theorem.
Now, if somebody were to say
to us, what's so important
about Rolle's theorem?
And this happens so often in
mathematics that frequently,
the most important thing about
one particular theorem, is
that it may be the building
block by which a more
important, or more
useful, or more
practical theorem is derived.
And in this respect, I would say
for my own opinion, that
the most important application
of Rolle's theorem is that it
facilitates a very famous result
known as the 'Mean
Value theorem'.
As our course proceeds, from
time to time we will have
ample reason to back track and
make references to the mean
value theorem.
I intend not to make too deep
references to the mean value
theorem now, because what
I would like to do is to
establish the result, give you
enough of an intuitive feeling
so that you can tuck it under
your belt without feeling too
overwhelmed by it, and just
enough applications of it so
that we can get into the next
phase of our calculus course.
But the mean value theorem is
another one of these things
where if you state the thing
analytically, and have no
feeling for what's going on
pictorially, the thing can
become overwhelming.
Let's, in fact, do it in an
overwhelming way, and then
show what the thing
means pictorially.
Notice again how this thing now
starts off the same way as
Rolle's theorem.
Let 'f' be continuous on the
closed interval from 'a' to
'b', and differentiable in the
open interval from 'a' to 'b'.
By the way, this is just an
idiosyncrasy of mine, I don't
know if it's standard.
When I talk about the closed
interval, I have the habit of
saying 'on' the interval.
When I talk about the open
interval, I like to say 'in'
the interval, to sort of
emphasize the interior.
It's just a vocabulary
trait, and don't read
too much into this.
Don't be upset by it.
But it's continuous on
the closed interval,
differentiable in the
open interval.
Now it's again an existence
theorem.
It says then there exists
a number 'c'.
When I say there exists,
it means what?
There is at least one number 'c'
in the open interval from
'a' to 'b'--
and this is the part that
looks kind of tough--
such that ''f of b' minus 'f of
a'' divided by 'b - a' is
'f prime of c'.
And this somehow or other may
seem at first glance to be
more ominous than the intuitive
feeling about
Rolle's theorem.
By the way, as the name implies,
where by 'mean' we
don't mean nasty, we mean
average, if you'd like to see
what this thing means, and I'll
draw you a picture in a
second, all it says is that if
a particle is moving from
point 'a' to point 'b', say, at
at least one point during
its trip, the instantaneous
speed must
equal the average speed.
You see?
Because after all, if you're
always going less than your
average speed, how could you
have had an average speed as
high as your average speed?
And if you're always going less
than your average speed,
how could you have had, you see,
an average speed equaling
this, what it did?
So that somehow or other, all
you're saying is that somehow
or other, the instantaneous
speed at a particular instance
must equal your average speed
someplace along the path.
Now what that means pictorially
is this--
again, I'll chance a
freehand diagram--
suppose our curve is 'y'
equals 'f of x'.
See, I've drawn it
to be smooth.
Suppose it's continuous and
smooth on this open interval
from 'a' to 'b'.
Now what is, if I think of a
particle moving from point 'p'
to point 'q', how do I identify
the average speed?
The average speed is the slope
of the straight line that
joins 'p' to 'q'.
On the other hand, what is
the instantaneous speed?
If we think of it in terms of
the picture, it's the slope of
the line tangent to the curve
at a particular point.
So in other words, what
we're saying is this.
You see, if we were to take the
line 'PQ', and we shift it
parallel to itself, I think you
can sense that the points
'P' and 'Q', if we labeled 'P'
and 'Q' the points at which
this chord intersects the curve,
the points 'P' and 'Q'
will roll in closer and
closer together.
Ultimately, the line will fail
to intersect the curve, and at
the transition point, if the
curve is smooth, all we're
saying is that the last point at
which that line touches the
curve as we move it out, OK,
that the line would be tangent
to the curve at that
particular point.
You see, all we're
saying is what?
That someplace between here and
here there must be a point
where the tangent line to
the curve is parallel
to the chord 'PQ'.
And now, we have all the
ingredients that we need to
see what the mean value theorem
says geometrically.
Let's call the tangent
line 'l'.
First of all, what is the
slope of the line 'PQ'?
Well, it's a straight line.
The slope of a straight
line is 'delta y'
divided by 'delta x'.
Well, notice that this
height here is by
definition 'f of b'.
This height here is 'f of a'.
So this height here is just
'f of b' minus 'f of a'.
This length here is
just 'b - a'.
So the slope, 'delta y' divided
by 'delta x', is just
''f of b' minus 'f of
a'', over 'b - a'.
On the other hand, what is the
slope of the line 'l'?
By definition, it's 'f prime of
x' evaluated at 'x' equals
'c', that's 'f prime of c'.
Now what does it mean in
terms of slopes for
two lines to be parallel?
It means that their
slopes are equal.
And where is 'c'?
'c' is someplace in the open
interval from 'a' to 'b'.
Now the reason I call this
intuitively an extension of
Rolle's theorem--
and by the way, you'll notice
that what I have to say is a
much simpler demonstration than
what's given in the book.
But before you think I'm being
egotistic about this, let me
point out, as is so often the
case that wherever my
demonstrations are easier than
the one in the book, I'm
losing something in
my presentation.
Either I haven't shown the most
analytic representation,
or I'm overlooking a particular
complicated side
effect that might occur.
But disregarding that for the
moment, you see what I'm
saying is this, let's suppose,
for the sake of argument, we
visualize the line 'PQ' as
being our new x-axis.
I'll call that the x1-axis.
And now let's take a line
perpendicular to 'PQ' and call
that our new y-axis,
the y1-axis.
Now look at the curve
that we've drawn.
With respect to the y1- x1-axis,
notice that the curve
is smooth, right?
It's unbroken.
And it cuts the x1-axis
at two points.
Now if we apply Rolle's theorem
with respect to the
x1- y1-axis, we say, look,
here's a curve
which cuts the x-axis--
the x1-axis--
at two points.
It's smooth.
Therefore, it must level
off someplace.
In other words, there must be
some point on this curve where
the tangent line to the curve
is parallel to the x1-axis.
That's exactly, you see, what
this thing here says.
That's another geometric
interpretation that indicates
how Rolle's theorem
might be used.
However, there is a very, very
subtle flaw in what I've said.
One that is so subtle that you
may not even notice it until I
point it out to you, and even
after I point it out, there's
a chance you may not realize
what I've said.
Because it's a point that I know
took me a long, long time
to discover for myself.
And it all hinges on
the concept of
single valuedness again.
The trouble with this
interpretation is the
following--
and by the way, let me point
out, I'm not knocking my
interpretation, I think it's
still a tremendous way of
visualizing the result, but from
an analytical point of
view, why we have
to be careful.
Let's suppose that my curve 'y'
equals 'f of x' happens to
look something like this, OK?
Happens to look something
like this.
Notice, barring any bad drawing
that I've done here,
that this curve is single value,
that no line parallel
to the y-axis cuts this curve
in more than one place.
Now here's my 'a' and
here's my 'b'.
And so I say, OK, by Rolle's
theorem, if I look at this as
being the x-axis and this
as being the y-axis--
in other words, the x1-
y1-axis again--
I say to myself, look, here's
a smooth curve, it cuts the
x-axis in two points, therefore,
someplace between
these two points, there must
be a place where the curve
levels off, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
And the interesting point is to
notice that a given curve,
as to whether it's single valued
or not, is dependent
upon the orientation
of the axes.
In other words, notice that
I've drawn this particular
curve so it is single valued
with respect to the xy-plane.
On the other hand, with
respect to the x1-
y1-coordinate system, this curve
is not single valued.
Namely, observe how a line
parallel to the y1-axis can
intersect this curve at
more than one point.
In other words, whether a curve
is single valued or not
is not an absolute property
independent of
the coordinate system.
So again, if I could be sure
that when I rotated my
coordinate axes the original
single valued curve was still
single valued, then
my above proof
would have been rigorous.
But of course, I can't
be sure of that.
By the way, the technique used
in the book is quite standard,
and what it does is the
following, it still utilizes
Rolle's theorem, but the
technique behind the proof in
the book is this.
The function that we set up is
the vertical distance between
the chord and the curve, as
we move along this way.
And notice that that distance
is 0 at these two endpoints.
OK?
And therefore, Rolle's theorem
applies to that function.
And the whole idea is
something like this.
All we say is--
and the analytic part
proves this--
all we say is look, the point at
which this chord would have
been tangent to the curve is the
place where the vertical
distance between the chord
and the curve is what?
Maximum.
And we won't go into that
right now, that
is done in the text.
All I wanted to do, as I always
will do when possible,
is that whenever the rigorous
proof seems far more
complicated than proofs which
are more intuitive, I will not
take the time in general, in our
lectures, to give the more
rigorous proof.
What I will take the time to
do is to show why the less
rigorous proof has pitfalls.
Well, enough said about
the statement of
the mean value theorem.
Time is getting very short, and
we don't need much more
time to make the home run
ball pitch that we
want to make now.
And the idea is this, that the
most important analytical
reason for having the mean value
theorem is, for those of
us who like to use our geometric
intuition, it turns
out that almost every
geometrically obvious fact
that has a proper analytic
counterpart has the property
that the analytic counterpart
is proven by
the mean value theorem.
See, let me give you a
simple for instance.
In fact, in the text book this
is called the first corollary
to the mean value theorem.
Suppose we have a function
capital 'F of x', and we know
that the derivative is
always equal to 0.
The claim is that 'F of x'
itself must be a constant.
By the way, two cautions here.
Don't say that we've had
this result before.
The result that we had
before was actually
the converse of this.
The result that we had before
was the one that said what?
If 'F of x' is a constant,
then its derivative is 0.
Now we're saying the
opposite--not the opposite,
but the converse.
Now we're saying, look, if the
derivative is always 0--
notice the use of my identity
symbol here--
if the derivative is 0 for all
values of 'x', then the
function must've been
a constant.
Now, you know, geometrically
this is a very
simple thing to visualize.
You say, look, the derivative
is the slope.
And if you're saying that the
slope of the curve is always
horizontal, the curve itself
must be a straight line.
And if the curve is a straight
line, that's exactly what you
mean by saying that the function
is a constant.
How do we prove this using
the mean value theorem?
See, and I just wanted to go
through a proof here once,
just so to get the idea
of what a proof means.
You see, to show that
something is a
constant should mean what?
That if 'a' is unequal to 'b'
for any two values 'a' and
'b', 'F of a'--
well, I'm using capital 'F'
here--capital 'F of a' has to
equal capital 'F of b'.
That's what you mean for a
function to be a constant.
No matter what the input is, the
outputs are always equal.
By the way, if 'a' equals 'b',
it's trivial that 'F of a'
equals 'F of b'.
But essentially, to prove that
capital F is a constant, this
is what I have to prove.
That if 'a' is different from
'b', no matter what 'a' and
'b' I use, that 'F of
a' equals 'F of b'.
And the idea is by the mean
value theorem, we say, look,
what does the mean value
theorem say?
We're assuming now that 'F'
is a continuous and
differentiable function on an
interval, OK, from 'a' to 'b'.
The mean value theorem says
under these conditions, there
exists a number 'c'
between 'a' and
'b' with what property?
That ''F of b' minus 'F of a''
over 'b - a' is equal to 'F
prime of c'.
That's just a statement of
the mean value theorem.
This is always true if the
conditions of the mean value
theorem apply.
Now all we're saying is, in this
particular problem, what
property that capital
'F' have?
It had the property that
its derivative for all
values of 'x' was 0.
In particular then, when 'c'
is the value that we're
talking about, if 'F prime of x'
is 0 for all values of 'x',
in particular, then, it's 0
when 'x' is equal to 'c'.
In other words, by our given
hypothesis, this is 0.
But if a fraction is 0, its
numerator must be 0.
That says what?
'F of b' minus 'F of a' is 0.
See, the only way a quotient
can be 0 is for the
numerator--
or the dividend, the divisor,
I don't know these formal
names, they slipped my mind, but
the top one has to be 0.
And if 'F of b' minus 'F of a'
is 0, that says 'F of b'
equals 'F of a', and that's
precisely what we had to show
to show that 'F'
was a constant.
OK?
So again, notice, it's not that
we're saying that the
mean value theorem is a harder
way of proving what we already
know to be intuitively true,
what we're saying is what?
That we know that many
intuitively obvious results
frequently turn out
to be false.
We would like some analytical
way of knowing which of the
intuitive results are
actually correct.
All I'm saying is the mean value
theorem gives us a big
hint that way.
By the way, let me close by
giving you one more important
illustration of what
we can prove by
the mean value theorem.
And this is called a corollary
of a corollary, as I'll show
you what I mean in a minute.
The next example that I want to
use is what it means to say
suppose I'm given two functions
'f' and 'g', and all
I know about these two
functions is that the
derivatives are identical.
In other ways, that 'f' and 'g'
have the property that for
every value of 'x', 'f
prime of x' is equal
to 'g prime of x'.
By the way, when I say every
value of 'x', again, it's
local versus global.
It's not necessary that this
happens for all 'x', what is
important is what?
That 'x' be defined
on some interval.
In other words, even if I know
that this property is true for
some interval, I don't really
care what happens outside of
that interval.
In terms of local properties,
all I'm saying is, all I know
is that for some interval, maybe
the whole axis, doesn't
make any difference, 'f prime'
is identical to 'g prime'.
Now, you would like to be able
to say, maybe, that if 'f
prime' is equal to 'g prime',
'f' equals 'g'.
But that's not the case.
What is the case is that the
difference between the two
functions must be a constant.
Again, geometrically, what
you're saying is what?
That if you have two curves,
which point by point always
have the same slope--
in other words, for each
'x' value, the
slopes are the same--
is just essentially
saying that the
two curves are parallel.
And if they're parallel curves,
what's a way of
stating that two curves
are parallel?
That one is a constant
displacement of the other.
In other words, the geometric
impact of two curves having
the same derivative is not that
the curves are the same,
but that they're parallel.
And by the way, the proof of
this result is again a
corollary to the mean
value theorem.
Namely, let's look at
the function 'f of
x' minus 'g of x'.
Call that capital 'F of x'.
Let capital 'F of x' be ''f
of x' minus 'g of x''.
Since the derivative of a
difference is the difference
of the derivatives, that would
say the derivative of capital
'F' is the derivative
little 'f' minus the
derivative of 'g'.
OK?
Now what do we know about 'f
prime' and 'g prime of x'?
We know that 'f prime of
x' equals 'g prime
of x' for all 'x'.
Consequently, the difference
between these two must be 0.
Remember, if two functions
are identical, their
difference is 0.
That says, therefore, that
capital 'F prime of x' is
identically 0.
And by our previous theorem--
notice the beautiful
logic of this--
from the mean value theorem,
we proved that if the
derivative of a function is
identically 0, the function
must be a constant.
So we apply that here.
But what was capital 'F'?
It was 'little 'f - g'.
And that proves our
desired result.
Again, what I want you to see
here is that we have not done
anything different with the
mean value theorem.
We're not trying to say we're
going to prove results we
couldn't prove before.
Rather, what?
The mean value theorem is our
way of showing that certain
intuitive results hold true
analytically, that we can talk
about parallel curves,
and things like this.
Most important, in terms of
summarizing this lecture from
a point of view of what's coming
next, it's crucial to
observe that this last example
is what is going to allow us
to enter the study of
something called the
'indefinite integral'.
Or in another manner of
speaking, something called the
inverse of taking
a derivative.
You see, the idea is, notice
that in these two examples we
start with information about
the derivative and deduce
what's true about the
original function.
That's inverting the emphasis
of what we've been doing up
until now, where we've started
with the function and
investigated its derivative.
To see this in more detail,
join me again next time.
And until next time, goodbye.
Funding for the publication of
this video was provided by the
Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.